- [Instructor] We've got some apples here
and we've got some oranges.
And what I wanna think
about is what is the ratio?
What is the ratio of apples,
of apples,
to oranges, to oranges?
And to clarify what
we're even talking about,
a ratio is giving us the relationship
between quantities of
two different things.
So there's a couple of ways
that we can specify this.
We can literally count
the number of apples,
one, two, three, four, five, six.
So we have six apples.
And we could say the ratio
is going to be six to,
six to, and then how
many oranges do we have?
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine.
It is six to nine.
Ratio of apples to oranges is six to nine.
And you could use different notation.
You could also write it this way.
Six to, you would still read it
as the ratio as being six to nine.
But we don't have to just
satisfy us with this,
because one way to think about ratios,
especially if we're thinking
about apples to oranges,
is how many apples do we have
for a certain number of oranges?
And when you think about it that way,
both six and nine are divisible by three.
So if you divide six
and nine both by three,
six divided by three is two,
and nine divided by three is three.
So we could also say that the
ratio of apples to oranges
is two to three.
Or if we want to use this notation,
two to three.
Two to three.
Now does that make sense?
Well, look, we divided each
of these groups into three.
So one way to think about it,
so if you divide,
if you divide this whole
total into three groups,
so one group,
one group,
two groups, two groups,
and three equal groups,
we see that in each of those groups,
for every two apples,
for every two apples
we have three oranges.
For two apples, we have three oranges.
So once again,
the ratio of apples to oranges,
for every two apples,
we have three oranges.
But we could think about things
the other way around as well.
We could also think
about what is the ratio,
ratio of oranges to apples,
orange to apples.
And here we would essentially
switch the numbers.
The ratio of oranges to apples.
Notice up here we said apples to oranges,
which is six to nine or two to three,
which is an equivalent ratio,
and here we're going to say
the ratio of oranges to apples.
So we swapped these two,
and so we're going to swap the numbers.
Here we have nine oranges
for every six apples,
so we could say the ratio
is going to be nine to six.
The ratio is nine to six,
or an equivalent ratio,
for every three oranges,
so we're gonna divide this by three,
so for every three oranges,
we are going to have two apples.
We are going to have two apples.
So notice this is just
exactly what we had up here,
but where we had apples to oranges,
it was six to nine,
six apples for every nine oranges,
and now when it's oranges to apples,
we say it's nine to six.
Nine oranges for every six apples.
Or we could say for every three oranges,
we have exactly two apples.